more what's happening in Ukraine I'm
joined Now by retired Air Vice Marshall
Sean Bell Sean what is the latest on the
strikes and the impact on power supply
and Kiev well translate it is becoming a
bit of a regular pattern isn't it the
Russian strikes on Ukrainian
infrastructure good example all across
the country good example in cave though
where they're still most of the city is
without power these are not military
targets the world health organizations
warned of a humanitarian catastrophe
looming because the hospitals are no
longer able to do critical operations
there why is Putin doing it well it
looks likely with his forces performing
badly on the battlefield that almost
certainly is closing in on the position
where he wants to negotiate wants to put
pressure on the Ukrainian population so
they actually lose the will to continue
fighting but I think that's almost
impossible to achieve and Defiance
example in Kiev last night was they were
playing Frank Sinatra's My Way on
loudspeakers in the city
what about the donbass this is an area
that we focused on a lot over the last
nine months but winter is coming isn't
it and it that's really going to change
the situation on the ground yeah it's a
situation up down to your right over
there the area of white is what the
Russians are still fighting for but the
weather's changed when winter is
arriving the rains are there thick mud
it's not going to stop the fighting but
it's become a bit of an artillery battle
as we go
um interesting though with only in about
six weeks time the temperatures will
plummet the ground will turn hard again
with the frost and it'll become
incredibly difficult minus 20 degrees or
potentially less than that the West is
supplying lots of specialist cold
weather equipment
um here's an example of Ukraine earlier
on this year when it in the rains it's
going to get a lot worse than this
um but of course the West providing lots
of high-tech equipment that will not be
available to the Russians with lots of
conscripts this is going to be
incredibly difficult and cold winter for
some of those Russian conscripts and how
do you think this is playing out back at
home for President Putin it it doesn't
seem to be going as he would have liked
it to have done how is he going to
bolster support
yeah so Russia on the back foot it's
done at least one mobilization allegedly
they're looking at potentially another
one morale's allegedly low and Russia
will want to be doing everything to
bolster support at home intelligence
reports that at Belgrade which is
literally just to the uh just inside uh
the Russian uh border there the Russians
are planning to do a false flag
operation in other words mount a some
sort of event which makes it look as if
Ukraine has invaded Russia and therefore
put the fear into the Russian population
and therefore Galvanize support in
reality for ukrainians nothing could be
further than shoot there's no motivation
from the go to Russia indeed it will
almost certainly be a red line for
Western support and Western weapons if
they were to do so and I think therefore
we've got to be really careful about how
we interpret anything we see in this
complex Information Age conflict okay
Sean thanks very much for that